hi this is prashta walker
this math problem was so hard it caused
an uproar over social media and had some
scottish students in tears
a crocodile is stalking a zebra that is
20 meters upstream on the opposite side
of a river
crocodiles travel at different speeds on
land and in water
the crocodile can stalk the prey faster
if it swims to a point p that is x
meters upstream on the other side of the
river
the time
taken in tenths of a second is given by
the following equation
part one calculate the time if the
crocodile does not travel on land
part two calculate the time if the
crocodile swims the shortest distance
possible
and part three calculate the shortest
time and the corresponding value of x
can you solve it
give this puzzle a try when you're ready
keep watching the video i'm going to
present the solution
and at the very end for part three i'm
going to present a solution they
probably would not have accepted but
it's what i would consider to be the
elegant solution and it actually can
help you solve many problems like this
so let's tackle the first part
calculate the time of the crocodile does
not travel on land
this means the crocodile travels
entirely in the water
this means the crocodile
is traveling all the way across
point p is all the way by the zebra
and so that means x is equal to 20.
we can substitute that value into the
equation for time
and find that the time taken is
approximately 104 tenths of a second
part two
calculate the time if the crocodile
swims the shortest distance possible
i was a little confused by the wording
the question what they mean is calculate
the time of the crocodile takes the
least amount of distance in the water
so that happens if the crocodile goes
directly across the water because any
other path the crocodile takes is going
to be a longer distance in the water
so basically the crocodile is traveling
all 20 meters
on land
so in this case x goes all the way x
meters upstream is zero
so the time will be equal
to 110 tenths of a second
part three calculate the shortest time
and the corresponding value of x
this problem is about calculus
and the standard way to solve this is
you take the derivative of the time and
set it equal to zero
you need to remember to use the chain
rule you want to take one half times 36
plus x squared raised to the power of
negative one-half and then remember to
multiply by 2x
if you can do that and set up this
equation
it requires a little bit of manipulation
but you'll eventually get that x equals
8 and the time is 98 tenths of a second
so this is probably the way they
expected students to solve it on the pro
on the exam
but there's a much more elegant way
and it actually brings into physics
so the first thing you need to do is
actually you need to reverse engineer
some of the question they've actually
given you the time it takes for the
crocodile to get to the zebra
what they've left out is some of the
background we actually don't usually
know
this kind of neat equation what we
usually get
is we just have to figure out all right
if you're traveling x meters upstream
that means the distance you're traveling
on land is 20 minus x so if you look at
the equation for time the 20 minus x
appears in the second part
so it's being multiplied by 4 because
that refers to the speed of the
crocodile
so we can kind of deduce the crocodile
must have a land speed of 1 4
meters per second
similarly if we look at the other part
of the equation we can see that 5 must
refer to the water speed
and in order to have that 36 plus x
squared where is that square root coming
from
this is because we have a hypotenuse
which must be the square root of 36 plus
x squared
and here we have six so there's a right
triangle form between the distance the
crocodile travels in the water the
amount x that travels upstream and we
can deduce the distance across the river
must be 6 in order for the hypotenuse to
be the square root of 36 plus x squared
so why are we reverse engineering this
you'll see in a second
so i'm going to get rid of some of the
problems and we're just going to make a
kind of physics
uh
analogy so right here
let's consider the path the crocodile
takes in the water and then the path the
crocodile takes on land so you could
think about this as light traveling
through two different mediums so imagine
light is traveling through water and
then it's going on land or you could
have you know maybe there's a classic
problem where a swimmer is running on
sand and then going into the ocean and
swimming and there are different rates
in these two mediums
so we set up these right triangles
and we have angles theta 1 and theta 2
from
the separation between the two mediums
the two the water and the land
and there's something called snell's law
which tells you a relation between these
angles
sine of theta one divided by sine of
theta 2
is always equal to the ratio of the
velocities in the two mediums
so where are the velocities coming from
in this case
we need to figure out this is why we
figured out what the land and the water
speed was
we actually have a special case before i
get to that in this case theta 2 you can
see is a 90 degree angle once you get to
land you're going straight
and so that means
this simplifies into sine of theta 1 is
equal to the ratio of the velocities
so what are the velocities in these two
mediums
well we had the water speed was
one-fifth and the land speed is
one-fourth
so that means the sine of theta one is
the ratio of one-fifth and one-fourth
which is four-fifth
now how does the sine of an angle ever
equal four-fifths
that only happens in a right triangle
specifically a three four five right
triangle
in our diagram we must have a three four
five right triangle
and we have the smallest leg that's
equal to six
so that means our hypotenuse is ten
and the other leg is eight because we've
doubled a three four five right triangle
and like magic we figured out that x has
to equal eight
we can substitute that back into the
equation for time and then we get time
equals ninety eight so it's a very
elegant solution if you use snell's law
this relates to optics and a bunch of
other physics problems
so this is probably not the answer they
would have wanted but it's a very cool
way to solve it
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalkar and if you like this
video please check out my books
there's links in the video description